hey youtubers is Charlie so the flash
officially premiered the season to suit
it just it has the white logo like that
the classic comics suit they were
showing it off at comic-con
but now they made it official like this
is the suit that Grant Gustin will be
wearing this year the real question we
need to ask now is is if they had not
seen that future newspaper with the
white logo would Cisco and Barry have
upgraded the suit this way that gets
into predestination time loops all kinds
awesome stuff that you normally just see
on Doctor Who and what about the suit
that Barry saw when he went back in time
to save his mother like the the
alternate version of Barry that told him
no don't save your mother he had the
white logo was that from the future or
was that from an alternate timeline all
good questions but this is the way I'm
thinking about it the Barry that told
our Barry to not save his mother the one
with the white logo in the finale is
from a timeline that predates season one
of the show in that timeline STAR Labs
wasn't created for like another five
years so the flash didn't become the
flash till much later professor zoom
came back in time and said he needed
those things to happen faster so he sped
up STAR Labs sped up the particle
accelerator so Barry became the flash
much much quicker that Barry is the one
that we were watching all of season one
so what happened to that other Barry
that predated season one of the show he
probably vanished into the ether the
same way professor zoom vanished
whenever Eddie killed himself
how does that explain the suit that they
saw on the Gideon computer because in
the future he still had the white logo
until they give us some more information
the way I'm thinking about that is is
that Barry was always destined to have
the white logo no matter when he became
the flash so no matter where he started
no matter what the first version of the
suit looked like it would have always
ended up looking like this that kind of
makes you think about the reverse flash
when he said that you know whenever you
tried to change history to avoid
something bad time always finds a way to
replace it with something that's just as
bad but but you know on the other side
of that it can be a good thing to and I
look at the the white logo is a good
thing so they didn't say which episode
this is gonna debut in presumably after
he comes out of that giant black hole in
the sky like presumably that's gonna
destroy the final suit because remember
he already trashed the spare suit so
like the suit that he's wearing in the
finale is the last one that they have so
they'll have to make
new one and what about Jay Garrick and
Wally West and what about that
mysterious teaser we saw with the the
blue looking flash and in actually based
on some of the things that the people
behind the show have said I'm choosing
to think of it as like the future blue
flash from the comics there was a little
bit of question as to like whether or
not it was supposed to be black flash
whether or not it was a speed Mirage
like like what was it so this is the way
I'm thinking about it this year in
season 1 we had the reverse flash with
the red lightning in the yellow suit we
had Barry with the red suit in the
yellow lightning so when they ran at
each other you know you could kind of
tell a little bit of a difference but it
imagines someone who doesn't understand
who the flash is what would you do to
make it really easy to distinguish who's
bad and who is good when they're moving
at SuperSpeed what you do just make them
different colors and it's really easy to
judge blue against yellow so in the new
52 comics there's a future version of
the flash that has a blue looking suit
it looks like this I think they're using
that as inspiration for zoom this year
just to distinguish him from the yellow
suit reverse flash of season 1 speaking
of which they haven't revealed who zoom
is gonna be who the big villains gonna
be but I think it's gonna end up being
Tom Cavanagh again because they said
that his version of Harrison wells will
probably come from earth-2 in the promo
Jay Garrick said your world is in danger
he's probably talking about zoom so zoom
will probably come from Earth too and
it'll probably be the alternate version
of Harrison wells
just for fun though here's a quick
rundown of all the different versions of
the flash suit in the comics when you
open it up to the multiverse there are
like 29 different versions of the flash
so I'm just gonna simplify this and just
do it like you know core flash members
we start out with Jay Garrick in his
golden age costume transitioning to
Barry Allen in the Silver Age the
costume on the show right now takes most
of its cues from that like with without
the nosepiece Wally West became the
flash slightly altered version of the
Barry Allen costume with the nose
covering back to Barry Allen and rebirth
who just were a shinier version of his
Silver Age costume for a brief period
Bart Allen took over as the flash in the
comics that in wore a version of Barry's
costume and then in the new 52 universe
the the biggest change they made was to
Jay Garrick like they reenact a as a
younger version any wore like a
dramatically different costume which I
am NOT a fan of there are many many
versions of the character
the multiverse and other members of the
flash family there are female speedsters
but those are just the core members of
the flash family the the people that
became flash proper typically members of
the flash family give themselves
different names like when Wally West is
not the flash he's Kid Flash I got
really excited when they confirmed patty
spivot was coming on the show that they
did that at comic-con because she was a
female speedster for a little while she
made she basically stole hot pursuits
gear and used that and she rode this
flash motorcycle it would be so awesome
if she did the Bad News Bears thing
where she rode into town on a motorcycle
in season two like that's how she
entered the frame we know they're doing
multiverse but but I don't think they're
gonna do speedster patty spivot I think
she'll just be a regular patty spivot
for most of the season one thing at a
time I'm hoping they don't do that thing
where they just they bring him out for a
single season like Malisse jowe played
Linda Park
she was really only in a couple episodes
hopefully she'll be back but they've got
so many new characters they're bringing
on that I'm not gonna hold my breath
patty spivot is really just like the
most exciting new female character
they're bringing she's supposed to have
a lot of chemistry with Barry they were
girlfriend-boyfriend in the new 52
universe but I don't think they're gonna
make it quite that literal on the show
if you haven't seen it go back and watch
Bad News Bears and watch for the girl
that rides in on the dirt bike
I just I'm hoping that's gonna be her
dynamic with the rest of the cast she's
just like the ringer cop that rides into
town on a motorcycle and just freaks
everyone out a little bit and excites
them at the same time let me know though
what do you think about the new flash
costume are you excited that they're
getting closer to the comics they made
the suit a little bit more red too if
you can't tell I mean it's kind of hard
to tell from this promo image but once
once you see it on screen like an in the
first trailer it'll make sense I'm
actually really curious to see what kind
of footage they show off in that first
trailer it might just be a trailer for
the premiere just because there's
there's so many things that they haven't
done yet it's not like Game of Thrones
where they have all the episodes shot by
the time they shoot the trailer so they
they have footage from like the final
episode in it speaking of which I'm
hoping that they drop the trailers for
the flash and arrow like the proper
trailers whenever vixen premieres that's
August 25th that's on a Tuesday that's
the same day the flashers on it just
makes sense that they would try to
promote the vixen premiere with new
footage from the flash and arrow if all
three shows are going to crossover and
congratulations to my Comic Con giveaway
winners chocobo kid and / owner you guys
both win 20
Amazon giftcards just be sure to message
me on the back end of my channel so I
can get your contact info in related
news I haven't done a Gotham video in a
little while so what I'm gonna do after
I do my Game of Thrones Q&A tonight is
I'm gonna do a Gotham season 2 video
because they did announce like a couple
really cool things they're doing on the
show Mr Freeze is probably the thing
that I'm most excited about that in
crazy Barbara that they're pushing her
in like the Harley Quinn direction she's
not gonna be Harley Quinn but she's
gonna be legit insane so while you guys
wait for all that stuff to post you can
click here to learn all about the new
arrow suit the arrow season 4 stuff that
they did at Comic Con and you can click
here to learn all about why people are
getting really crazy about Game of
Thrones season 6 in the Tower of joy
thank you so much watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight